so first of all before we get started I
have to give a huge thank you to the
house of Aurora because they're the
reasons why we get to be in this awesome
location and so I just want to give them
a huge shout out because the only reason
I get to cover festivals is partnering
up with people so thank you House of
Aurora on that note you've probably
thank them every interview haven't you
yeah no no [ __ ] I have and by the
way but I'm really sincere I really
thank them because it's really expensive
to bring a huge crew up here and to put
on all this and so I mean it you have to
have a sponsor and they hydrate your
guests with delicious beverages yes a
hundred percent delicious these
beverages are delicious
wait hold on one second what's the name
of the company again space bear I want a
spare I want to give it a huge thank you
to space fair as well I cannot wait to
see Halloween I think I speak for like
everyone in since you guys announced you
we're gonna do it and tonight is the big
premiere what is going through your
brain right now first of all how did you
decide on premiering at Toronto with the
midnight movie was it a studio was it
you guys well I've come to Toronto with
my last five movies in a row and and I
didn't even think about the fact that
this doesn't really strike the world as
a traditional Film Festival movie but
when we were talking about it we were
wrapping up our post-production on the
movie and early summer and think about
what our strategy for going out with it
was and I just Toronto just kind of a
part of my instinctive filmmaking diet
so I thought why don't we let me see
what people think
yeah what's interesting is you guys I
think it might be the only movie that's
like you're playing once you either get
a ticket to the midnight tonight or
you're [ __ ] like that's it
so I mean what who's motivation was it
to just show it one night and either you
get lucky or you don't
yeah it's a good plan right but the fun
part too is like you know typically and
I don't know you know you get a film
festival there's press screenings people
are writing about movies before the
crowds have seen it and it's like let's
just go have fun and watch a movie at
midnight with a bunch of people that
like slasher movies and see what see
what the world thinks it's the way to
just really put it out there in the
right way the right presentation the
right audience and and we're excited
about it
no completely I was just stunned that
there was like no like press screening
it's like even after you play it tonight
it's just done get out of there yeah
exactly watch it again right when it
comes out buy a ticket bridge for both
of you I know you've probably talked a
little bit about this before but I want
to ask what what was it like getting the
keys to this kingdom and having like the
freedom to make this movie
I mean it was pretty insane it was crazy
once we were on it and then it was like
oh I just get to watch all the Halloween
movies over and over each night and it's
part of my job it was awesome I don't
think we really when David asked me to
jump on this with him I don't think I
ever imagined that we would end up like
going through till the end I was like
well we'll come up with a pitch and then
they'll choose somebody more suitable
for this and and then the next thing I
knew we were like pitching John
Carpenter and it was insane it was crazy
that they that they let us do this but
it was a blast I mean Halloween is such
an influential horror film it's a movie
I've loved for since I first saw it as a
kid and to be able to kind of play
around in that world with characters
like Laurie Strode and Michael Myers and
kind of figure out what happens next
with them it's unreal what was it like
for you getting the keys to this kingdom
well exactly what Danny said I mean it's
a tremendous opportunity it's also one
of those things that is exciting as the
initial idea is you really got to think
does it need to exist and if and if we
are going to embark on such a fragile
journey you know there's such a
tremendous fan base for the franchise
and any direction that you choose is
gonna piss off X piece of the pie of the
fan base and so you have to really think
how do you personalize make it important
to you so that you can stand here at
Toronto and and talk about it
passionately and personally and what the
movie means to us because we engineered
something that we were passionate about
so it was taking something that has a
greatness we have a great nostalgia for
in John Carpenter's film and and taking
it very seriously having a ton of fun
and figuring out how to involve
carpenter how to involve Jamie Lee
Curtis and how to utilize the tools that
that original film taught us to make the
film necessary
because otherwise why do it it's not a
money grab type of movie you're not
making Halloween 11 which technically we
are but for our mindset let's go let's
go make the sequel to the first film
that never happened completely what was
it like did you have any sort of battle
with the MPAA or was it a pretty smooth
sailing experience it was just a
straight-up r-rating see you later got a
movie yeah
really you'd have to like cut a few
frames here and there no no I mean it's
you know we found that line and it was
it was part of the creative challenge of
it was like when we're gonna shoot
something that you know is gore let's
let's not let's find what that line is
and you know much like the original film
it
it doesn't this scares don't revolve
around how grotesque and images there
and there are some grotesque images but
we we want them to be narrative ly
justified and not just you know not just
gross to be gross but trick
we had Christopher Nelson who's an
incredible makeup and effects artist and
and and you know we were not pulling any
punches but all within what we found was
a pretty honest engineering in response
to the original film one of the things I
found is that sometimes it's way scarier
when you don't see it when you just hear
it
and when it's you know just off frame so
and I noticed in some of the footage
that I've seen some of it is just off
frame can you talk about how you wanted
to frame certain things in the movie and
if you were playing with sort of that
thing letting people use their
imagination more it was always part of a
conversation you know what to see yeah
you know Danny I would talk about and
Jeff radley our co-writer we would watch
movies all the time and talk about hey
here's where suspense really works
here's where jumping a jump scare will
really be effective so surprise for
suspense gore versus restraint and
imagination and so we just tried to find
that balance and and honestly I found
that balance in editing because this is
my first horror film I shot it all every
way I could you know considering it was
a 25 day shoot we went in there to say
hey I want to I think I know what I want
but I want to make sure if in the
editing room or
if when I'm when I'm showing a test
audience the movie I can learn from that
and I can see I could you know I could
play it one way or the other and try to
finesse the engineering of it for both
of you obviously this is the
continuation of the original movie and
you know it but this is a beloved
franchise that I'm sure the studio if
this is successful would love to see
more of or spin-offs or whatever because
that's the universe we live in now how
much are you guys or when you were
pitching it
were you just this is a one-off this is
our idea and how much were you sort of
in that initial meeting saying hey if
this works we also have this we
definitely thought about it in a bigger
picture of where we would go if we had
more but I think we were both of the
mindset of like let's just see if we
don't like blow it with this one and not
get ahead of ourselves create a whole
universe and then no one likes it there
was a point we were talking about doing
to it one time and thinking wouldn't it
be ambitious and then yeah we got a
little scared trying to get it you know
didn't want to get ahead of ourselves
I'm curious from when you first started
coming up with the idea to what people
are seeing on screen do you guys go
through just like a ton of different
versions or did it sort of naturally
come together where was a very smooth
writing process you know I mean write
and do different drafts it evolves and
uh and we we're definitely guys that
don't just like write one draft and
that's it we're constantly like
challenging the material even on the set
and I think the general concept of this
came out pretty quickly but then as we
sort of started to kind of like write
for Laurie Strode and kind of develop
these other characters I then we did
evolve like the concept of it greatly I
think I think for us it was a matter of
just like writing enough for these
characters to feel a little bit of
ownership over them and then being able
to figure out what the audience was
gonna think was interesting there are
some I love the shots that I've seen of
like because you you take place on
Halloween where people are walking
around and it's great so talk a little
bit about filming like that kind of
sequence when everyone is in costume and
there is there he is you know what I
mean
yeah and again it's a low-budget movie
and so you don't have the the the
streets all roped off and as you would
on some on a bigger picture and there's
there's neighbors starting to come into
the house wanting to get a glimpse of
Michael Myers and we were very we were
trying to be very discreet about how the
mask would be revealed because we didn't
want
you know shots end up online and in bad
lighting and things like that and out of
context which the the mask I don't know
if you know but it's a very specific
type of thing if you were just looking
at it in broad daylight you might roll
your eyes but if you put it in the right
lighting and you have the right shape
underneath it it starts to take on this
kind of menacing character but you all
have to be very specific even through
the editing process with how the mask is
seen and I was really paranoid you'd to
see some sort of you know paparazzi type
snapshot of of it looking crummy and
people think oh that's what they're
doing so we were trying to be very
protective in an environment so we were
manok we close off neighborhoods as best
we can but try to keep it really
intimate and shooting between two or
three houses and and when you'd see kids
look at Michael Myers for the first time
it was an amazing effect even you know
we're talking about six seven eight nine
ten year olds that probably have no idea
the iconic monster movie monster that
they're they're looking at but just the
suspicion and fear in their eyes just
watching you know as our as our you know
our actor would into the the the set was
pretty fun how long was your first cut
compared to the finished film first cut
was like two hours and 15 minutes I
think we saved about a half hour out of
that so we're hour 45 was it like a lot
of fat or was it did you actually remove
a bunch of scenes both you know as I
said it was like a very exploratory
process and shooting and shooting as
much as we could and options and then
realizing much like we do in the
screenwriting process that that you
might be spelling something out too much
you know and so the simplicity is more
our audiences are smart in a slasher
film audience knows what they're going
to see a movie for do you really need to
give a ton of backstory or can we cut to
the chase and get to what's scary get to
what's fun and get to what makes this
franchise unique I definitely have to
know has John Cena he's obviously seen
what am i starving her yeah yeah I was
gonna say what am I saying but I want to
rewind what was his reaction what is it
like showing it to him for the first
time because I mean are you sitting
outside the room like basically scared
shitless or you did he know so much
going in that it wasn't really he wasn't
you know nothing was unexpected it was
it was very under Matic because he was
so involved so the scripts face so he
was watching it and we were you know I
well we were on a Skype session and he
was watching so I was watching him while
I was watching the back of his head
watch it and then he'd give me thumbs up
[Laughter]
and then we got right to work and making
music for us so he saw a very vulnerable
over long version of the movie and then
was giving notes as to what he would do
or some ideas as to how to tighten it
and how much were you on set
you know we shot this in Charleston
South Carolina where we live so we would
uh you know we'd come by all the time it
was great to be able to bring something
like Halloween to your own backyard and
uh like her kids came by the set like I
was six girls son and he's seen Michael
Myers in person that's a you know if I
can give him one thing this world I
think I've done it yeah oh did you do
any sort of like secret cameo in the
background or you're just walking by to
see that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what is it like though I really am
curious about the editing process and
what you who do you guys typically show
a movie to or show to for like real
honest feedback because or people afraid
you know what I mean like are people
afraid to be like there's three tiers of
people that I look - there's our
immediate friends that that will tell
you exactly what they think there's
another wave of people that just till
tell you what they think you want to
hear and you can't trust them and then
the unsuspecting audience the blind
recruited audience that you you know get
a couple hundred people that you don't
know and you don't tell them what
they're about to see and and for me
that's outside of maybe five or six
really close collaborators of mine it's
it's the the the people that the
uninitiated entering the audience that
are gonna they're gonna shoot me
straight I'm gonna watch them watch it
and I'm gonna encounter the roller
coaster that I'm trying to design for
them and I'm most gulped it accordingly
I know I'm basically out of time with um
just gonna ask them quick quick last
things what's the story with the
newsflash newsflash it's just a project
I'm developing and could be really cool
about
Walter Cronkite no I know I'm very okay
I wanted to know if it was moving
forward or because it sounds really too
busy to jump on it right now but
hopefully we get to make that here in
the near future and what about this
Friday Night Lights thing I just turned
in the draft we'll see if people want to
make that move yeah but I wrote a
American football movie
no no I'm yeah yeah so what else you
guys work together all the time
obviously you've wrapped now in
Halloween what is the next thing for the
two of you working on together you know
we just finished this this pilot for a
new HBO show that we just turned into
them
so if HBO greenlight said that would
probably be one of the next things we'd
work on yeah and the title the righteous
gemstones yeah I was wondering about
what the status was with that job I
think you have a decent track record
with HBO I would like to think that they
would want to work together again yeah
we got a good cast - I think we're
pretty happy with it so we'll see what
they think
yeah I know you got to go but I just
have to thank you for Vice Principals
because that was what we call a good
show good thank you no thanks a lot also
there was this thing called eastbound
and something you know and also I think
HBO did this Crocodile Dundee tourism
campaign no that was something else that
was something else
right listen I mean it's so sincerely I
cannot wait to see Halloween thank you
so much for coming in the studio thank
you again to House of Aurora for having
me and us and enjoy the premiere tonight
I'm sure we're gonna love it thanks a
lot later
[Music]